there's a new force stirring in British
politics in some ways it looks quite
like an old one and in some ways it
might be something brand new a politics
born of fury the brexit party freshly
minted only months ago by Nigel Faraj is
already topping some polls for the
European elections and the party can
boast thousands of foot soldiers like
these at only their second rally in
Birmingham
there are many Xu Kip many Tories and
some non-aligned at all but wherever
they're from one thing unites them what
brings me here today
somebody took in one word democracy why
didn't we just leave and then they go
che why are we sticking more wishes may
says because people are going to lose
their jobs people what about you people
I don't care because I believe I want
democracy at any cost and there's of
course one man who brings him here they
love him he's a folk hero and not only
does he have a new party but Mewtwo's he
wields now not only brexit or betrayal
alone but a more powerful weapon still
the idea of British national humiliation
a weapon he intends to use treating the
mrs. main wants to get signed through
the House of Commons is such a shameful
document it could only ever have been
signed by somebody who had been defeated
in war it is a travesty
right
backstage furrows reflects to me that he
believes these new themes that go to the
heart of our democracy could grant him
bigger success and he's ever heard our
ambitions here are not just to go out
win the European elections the ambitions
are to change politics for the good to
really reshape and we orientate British
policy what do you think the average
breaks apart though it looks like I mean
is it just the leaf boater or do you
think that it's bigger than that the
sort of leap I think it is bigger than
that potentially remain as well I think
the argument that we are one of the
oldest functioning democracies in the
world that has seen democracy produced
by our career politicians over the last
couple of years is a very powerful
argument Pharos believes Parliament has
set itself against the people so now he
will set the people against them
[Applause]
and it's the power of these emotions
more powerful than even what we saw in
2016 which are propelling this new
movement you know you could just feel in
the room is electric and it isn't just
about it's about it's for the
transformation of politics
politics jealousy there is a set of
people equally angry on the remain side
about breakfast but Faraj is bringing
the lead coalition together as remain as
state bracket
no one has channeled the remainders and
their anger as Faraj is channeling his
people and theirs that might yet be
remain as down for you and his second
victory Lewis got all Sky News London